misiles de largo alcance vuelan
alrededor de taiwán por primera vez en
un cuarto de siglo en el marco de unos
ejercicios militares sin precedentes que
china ha lanzado alrededor de la isla un
día después de que la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu nancy
pelosi visitara taipei made with housing
6 y estados unidos hizo una provocación
maliciosa y china se ha visto obligada a
actuar en defensa propia así que
cualquier cosa que hayamos hecho en
respuesta como contramedida es
justificada firme y categórica quien
llega y olvida por mar y por aire
beijing está realizando simulacros con
fuego real en seis zonas que rodean a
taiwán y está previsto que continúen
hasta el domingo los buques comerciales
se han visto obligados a desviarse en
una de las rutas de carga más
transitadas del mundo china también ha
bloqueado las exportaciones e
importaciones de diversos productos
hacia y desde taiwán al tiempo que ha
intensificado las sanciones económicas
para castigar al gobierno de la isla
dirigido por la presidenta chagin wen
aquí en beijing considera separatista
el temor a una escalada militar las
autoridades taiwanesas se mantienen
desafiantes y prometen reforzar sus
defensas y mantener estrechos lazos con
eeuu un método juntos defenderemos el
orden internacional basado en normas
evitando una nueva escalada regional y
protegiendo enérgicamente la seguridad
del estrecho de taiwán y la libertad la
apertura la paz y la estabilidad de la
región indo pacífica que el shopping
cuenta también aumentan las tensiones
diplomáticas el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de china ha cancelado una
reunión con su homólogo japonés al
margen de la reunión de la asean en
protesta por una declaración emitida por
el g7 en la que se pedía una resolución
pacífica del conflicto
beijing la calificó de desvergonzada ya
que recuerda a la alianza de las ocho
naciones que invadió china en 1900